[Musique]
45 % de son activité est réalisée dans
le secteur automobile le groupe elitech
emploie plus de 500 salariés
son activité validé et certifié le bon
fonctionnement des produits testés
aujourd'hui l'entreprise bénéficie du
plan en france relance notamment pour le
développement du véhicule du futur et
pour en parler nous sommes avec
sébastien poteau bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
et
vous êtes le directeur des opérations
autour de la mobilité au sein du groupe
elitech comment avez vous vécu cette
année 2020 et l'impact de la crise
sanitaire
alors chez les mitec est
particulièrement un secteur de la
mobilité on a vécu deux crises ou deux
changements majeurs on va dire une crise
la crise du comice bien sûr et puis une
crise sectorielle une mutation
sectorielle puisque quand vous avez pu
le voir on voit de plus en plus de
véhicules électrifiés emitech père était
partie prenante des tests autour des
véhicules électrifiés que ce soit sur
les batteries goût sur les moteurs
électriques contesté aussi beaucoup de
moteurs à combustion sur les sites
d'achères et nous aurons mois il a fallu
accélérer notre développement de moyens
d'essais de compétences sur toute
l'année 2019 et surtout 2020 pour
pouvoir prendre le virage des
validations de ces deux composants
majeurs à savoir la batterie les moteurs
électriques et son électronique de
puissance
finalement c'est une crise qui a eu un
impact je peux sur votre activité avec
une chute peut être de votre chiffre
d'affaires mais en même temps il ya une
opportunité derrière exactement dans
toute crise il ya une opportunité alors
la cheffe de la baisse du chiffre
d'affaires d'affaires en 2020 a été
significative
on faisait à peu près 15 % on est aux
alentours de 48 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en 2020 on en faisait
55 en 2019
donc c'est une baisse significative mais
effectivement il ya une opportunité
puisque il ya le développement des
véhicules électriques électrifié
qu'elles soient des hybrides ou des
véhicules 100% électriques
elle est
elle est vraiment très forte progression
de veau au niveau des ventes de nos
clients et nous ça nous amène des gros
challenge d'adapter nos moyens d'essais
de repenser nos compétences autour de ce
véhicule électrifiée et on est en train
de préparer aussi activement le véhicule
avec une combustion hydrogène que ce
soit la pile à combustible ou le moteur
thermique avec un carburant hydrogène et
pour accompagner ce changement à l'état
vous accompagner à travers le fonds de
modernisation de l'automobile et de
l'aéronautique alors vous avez bénéficié
de combien est qu à quoi va servir cet
investissement on a déposé un projet en
septembre 2020 au plein coeur de la
crise on a une réponse positive de
l'état de la bpi fin d'année 2020 donc
on va recevoir une subvention d'environ
900 mille euros qui va servir à créer ou
moderniser des bancs d'essai autour de
trois thématiques des essais de
compatibilité électromagnétique pour les
moteurs électriques des bancs de test
pour les batteries de cyclage électrique
et thermique et être capable de proposer
aussi des essais feu sur les batteries
pour valider le bon fonctionnement des
batteries même sous des environnements
très agressif comme le feu et cette
activité se déroule à
montigny-le-bretonneux je crois qu'on va
aller le voir c'est ça
exactement l'un des bancs se déroule à
montigny d'entonner en plein cours de
construction
et on va les doigts
c'est un banc pour tester les moteurs
électriques qui participent à la
traction des véhicules qu'ils soient
électriques ou hybrides
donc c'est la tendance actuelle du
marché automobile
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire lentement
on va venir tester des moteurs
électriques et vérifier la compatibilité
électromagnétique de ses moteurs
c'est à dire c'est à dire on va vérifier
que ses moteurs en fonctionnement
n'émettent pas trop d'ondés
électromagnétiques ou au moins dans les
normes qui sont définies et qui ne sont
pas perturbés par les ondes
électromagnétiques qui sont dans la
nature quand on passe sous une ligne
haute tension et c'est parce que ça peut
perturber leur fonctionnement c'est ça
peut perturber le fonctionnement donc il
ya des normes
c'est une première en france puisque des
banques comme ça il y en a c'est le
premier qui va être construit en france
donc qu'est ce qui va permettre de faire
il va permettre de tester sous charge
donc en rotation le moteur électrique
la spécificité de cette cage c'est
qu'elle elle filtre tous les ondes
électromagnétiques qui viennent de
l'extérieur et elle fait elle elle
empêche aussi les ondes
électromagnétiques qu'on va induire dans
cette cage vers l'extérieur donc après
la spécificité de cette de ce banc c'est
d'avoir un dispositif qui va permettre
d'entraîner le moteur électrique du
client
encore une fois je le rappelle qui va
être ici par une génératrice de charges
qui est ici donc la difficulté de ce
banc c'est un la vitesse de rotation
puisqu'on va tourner à plus de 22 mille
tours minute
donc il ya nécessité de très bien
alignées l'arbre de la machine
électrique avec le prototype clients
donc là on a déposé on a
réalisé un gros travail au sein de notre
bureau d'études avec des partenaires
merci sébastien poteau merci directeur
des opérations autour de la mobilité au
sein du groupe et vittek